I've read something from the mail online
right now this Brady Brady sent me a
link to this and it combines all my
worst I don't know bug bears or all of
the things that really irritated me gray
my gears get me under must get under my
skin first of all it's the Daily Mail
that's why I send it to you I know I
know
it's a Daily Mail which is the bastion
of reactionary right-of-center news and
storytelling in in the UK the UK would
be a hell of a lot better britain would
be a hell of a lot better if we didn't
have a deal email that's the first thing
then it's combined with them well as you
can see quantum physics proves that
there is an afterlife and claims like
yeah one expert claims use evidence to
confirm an existence beyond the grave
and it lies in quantum physics so now
we're getting into the area of quantum
physics whoo and the whole idea that you
know there's a fantastical element to
quantum mechanics we're all one part of
one integrated interconnected whole the
the weird and wacky and wonderful stuff
that that happens right down at the
atomic molecular level and we are done
wacky and wonderful stuff does happen
down there somehow magically transmute
so magically you can scale up to the
real world so we've got all these
fascinating effects happening and sort
of everyday land scales it's really
frustrating because this this doesn't
seem to be new stuff I don't quite know
why this has suddenly come to the fore
but it's this guy called Robert Lanza
now Robert Lanza is obviously a very
clever guy he's done a lot of really
neat working stem-cell research it seems
I'm not a stem-cell researcher so I
haven't read his work in detail but what
I do know is that he's got no background
in physics and of course the usual
argument is or that means that's great
because he's coming from left field he
controlled the establishment I take the
ideas away and he'll come up with these
radical new ideas that's sort of like me
going well you know I've absolutely no
background in surgery but I'll tell you
what I'm going to go in I'm going to get
in there at the operating table I'm
going to develop some really new
techniques oh dear I've made a mess it's
you know the the argument that you know
left of failed ideas can come from you
know very different places than you
might expect that's true but you know
what's what's the quote of fortune
favors the prepared
and you know there has to be some level
of background oh you've got to think
about what the history of the field has
been you've got to try and work your way
through what he's basically saying it's
actually not that much different from a
book called the tower physics very
famous book has been out there an hour I
guess since the 70s I can't quite
remember maybe even the 60s and what it
does is it connects New Age ideas sort
of Eastern mysticism with quantum
mechanics and quantum physics the idea
that you know quantum physics means that
there's an interconnectedness to all
things and with his own universal spirit
it said all these type of things which
are deeply deeply frustrating because
your quantum physics really says no such
thing at all and what Lance has done is
he's gone a little bit further and he's
basically taking the old idea of the
observer affecting a measurement of the
observer affecting an object to say that
actually there is no objective reality
out there there is no universe that are
there it's our consciousness it's our
biochemistry that creates a universe I
need a bit of deep breath because it is
frustrating ah how can I put it off a
lot of nonsense in this let's be
sympathetic for a minute what has the
world of quantum mechanics and
physicists done wrong that allows people
to start making these connections that
you think experience that's a really
great question and I think I was guilty
of this as everyone else because when
you're down at the atomic molecular
single particle level weird things do
happen things that we don't understand
but because we don't understand them
doesn't mean we can just make up any
nonsense we can't just say alright we
don't understand some aspect of quantum
mechanics then I don't know that's
because invincible pixies which are
undetectable to us or popping in and out
of existence and affecting the forces
between these particles we don't have a
license to just make a ball problem is
all the weird and whacky stuff that
happens at the atomic molecular level
like particles of this jute jewel or
schizophrenic character where they have
behaved like waves you know we haven't
got to the bottom of that we really
don't understand what's going on there
in particular something called quantum
entanglement where you know which lands
have describes but at length and he's
right
that it is weird and it is strange in
that you get two particles you couple
them together in some weird state is
called an entangled state I'm not going
to go into details for the physicists
among you you you know it's all about
spin and all that type of thing but you
couple them in some state called an
entangled state that's all we need to go
into you send one particle to one end of
the universe
if the universes ends the other particle
to the other end of the universe you
make a measurement on this one and
here's the the weird bit the bit that
course causes so many physicists so many
sleepless nights is that you make a
measurement in this one and this one
responds instantaneously not at the
speed of light instantaneously there's
clearly something you know that we're
lacking there we don't understand that
it's a remarkable effect but physicists
work extremely hard to try and see these
effects they ultra-high vacuum and very
very very low temperatures those type of
effects do not scale up to the
macroscopic world the reason all this
quantum weirdness we don't see it in the
macroscopic world you know I don't
diffract like a wave when I go through a
door Brady is a fairly solid object in
front of me it's you know it doesn't
seem to have wave-like characteristics
at all and that's because we interact
with ultimately it's because we interact
with our environment and that doesn't
require consciousness it's just you know
there's just a very fact that these
waves these quantum waves are getting
scattered of objects that's enough we
don't need a consciousness to be an
observer and that's one of the
difficulties with this is the sort of
anthropomorphic aspect of this is that
you're assuming that nature that the
reality has to be observed by a
conscious observer to create this stuff
to come back to your question Brady
which is a great question you know to be
fair we're so desperate to put across
look at how weird and wonderful this
stuff is it's it's it's fascinating and
it is fascinating but the difficulty is
is that sometimes that's misinterpreted
and quite how we get beyond I quite how
women Tay and look at how exciting this
is and yet get across that well actually
you've got to be very careful before you
extend this
to larger skills physicists are very
guilty for various reasons of borrowing
language from the macroscopic world to
describe this world don't they you know
we talk about colors and flavors of
quirks and we talk and you borrow all
this language to help people understand
yeah and then it's misinterpreted yeah I
agree
quirk is actually a pretty good one cuz
that's a I would argue that's a you know
of all the words leeward it doesn't
connect really to the world around us
color is a problem but one of the things
being is a problem spin is a big problem
because spin is is not spin that's the
difficult it's not spin as we think it
cuz if you do the calculation it turns
out that if spin at the quantum level
was actually spin things would be
spinning around it so many times the
speed of light so it's yeah that it is a
problem what's Thank You brilliant we
didn't even prepare this at all so I've
been reading this as opposed in
principle which it's remarkable you can
see the origin and validation of a
scientific principle and this principle
I'm not going to go into it but it's to
do with spin and actually without this
principle we wouldn't have a periodic
table but it's absolutely remarkable
because Pioli didn't introduce it as
spin he called it something I'd
translated vaguely from the German
something along the lines of a two
valued electron thing and that
eventually became spin and it's not
quite spin it's definitely not spin it's
a I think most physicists would think of
it as it's a property of an electron and
we label it as plus or minus 1/2 but
actually what it physically represents
is something very very difficult indeed
Lancer it basically exploit that I would
say there's another line in this Daily
Mail article answer uses the example of
the way we perceive the world around us
a person sees a blue sky sky and is told
that the color they are seeing is blue
but the cells in a person's brain could
be changed to make the sky look green or
red yeah ok that's that's that's fine
I'm not an exponent biochemistry but
yeah I can see how that might be the
kids but that's like arguing that there
isn't an objective color there but we
can measure an objective color because
we know the wavelength or we can measure
the wavelength of the light that might
Oh brains might perceive that as red or
green or blue whatever but when you know
what that wavelength is or what the
frequency of that light is so there was
an objective color there
and it's this mixing of you know quantum
ideas with the idea of what is
subjective and what is objective I guess
that makes this for physicists so
painful to read but for others
who don't you know don't have the
background in physics they read this and
go well he's using lots of big words
here physicists use those same type of
big words then therefore I don't send
too patronizing but you know there could
be an argument well you know the
language there seems to be the language
of a physicist so maybe he's um maybe
he's onto something here and when you
couple out with her you know he's coming
from left failures no training in
physics it's it's really oh it's it's
really a neat story it's a compelling
story in terms of the loan are really
battling against the system to show that
he's got a wonderful new out you know
out of left field theory why does it
matter because no physicist is going to
accept this and he hasn't said anything
that's going to make the average reader
go and jump off a cliff or do something
stupid why does it matter that some
people think that maybe a misguided
article is accurate because it changes
the perception of physics it changes the
perception of the world around us and my
job as a physicist and everyone's job as
a physicist is to understand the world
around us and moreover we're funded were
funded by the public the reason we do
these videos the reason we produce
papers is to disseminate our work to say
look this is the way the world is and
that's why it hacks off so many
physicists is because it's false it's
just fundamentally wrong it's like I
don't know it's you're a journalist
Brady it's like somebody coming up you
you work really really hard to you know
get the detail of a story and tell that
is accurately as possible and then some
likely in the Daily Mail journalist
comes along and gives a completely
distorted version of the facts they put
they would hack you off and for
physicists it's it's not only dangerous
from that perspective in terms of the
overall public perception it's also
dangerous in terms of you know where how
politicians view what's what's happening
because you know politicians who are in
many cases don't have a strong
scientific background may well read this
and think oh wow and if they've got any
sort of influence I guess on the funding
system and the funding ecosystem if you
want to call
that then you know this could direct
funding away from something which is a
hell of a lot more valuable into this
this type of nonsense in this particular
system you can't it doesn't work for
this system and it doesn't work for so
many systems because what you have to do
is to have a limit to have an upper
limit on the total amount of energy you
can have